I Rick Owens I'm maturely the CEO
tougher where brands and part of the
diversity group here in Davos we just
had a terrific meeting I want to come in
on the president of Philippines glorious
wonderful message about diversity and
we've learned in our company that
diversity and this whole thing about
gender parity isn't just something thats
altruistic and nice to do it's a source
of competitive advantage so we've spent
the last year kind of educating as many
people as we can across the world on are
the differences between men and women
how to leverage that very strong
difference and the talents that each
brings to the party anyway we think will
make more progress this next year take
care bye sorry what am i hitting wrong
okay got it